first off I've deployed an army of 30
hungry customers who'll invade each
restaurant in turn and all order at once
they're on their way to sample the food
on offer at the 16th century manor house
an estate at winching and fields in
Lincolnshire
what I like most about this place is
it's it's quaint and it's like a little
mini oasis and also they depend on the
local ingredients stuff produced on
their doorstep and they turn that into
the most amazing food hi guys
listen well I've forgotten how beautiful
this place is amazing amazing amazing
five years ago husband-and-wife team
Colin and Ben put everything they had
into this stunning restaurant while back
take care of front of house Colin heads
up the kitchen Service face is a face
Ben wait a minute
he creates exciting modern dishes
capturing all the fantastic flavors of
great French cuisine without the
heaviness lobster risotto I'm excited
about this delicious
Colin is pulling out all the stops to
put this place on the map the restaurant
boasts a five grand champagne on the
menu one waiter for every two customers
and even has its own helicopter pad
this is the the lambing facilities for
the restaurant we give them the
coordinates and then we just pick them
up yeah they've got all the staff all
the gear the most amazing kitchen
there's obviously a lot riding on this
you see it in Colin's face he's under
pressure big time
this is on the five minutes from now
that my daughters will be here and they
are so excited about walking into winter
young fields and being blown away you
have dedicated your life to get this
place right really make this count big
test today
two hours 30 of my diners two corsets
make sure they leave on cloud nine good
luck my 30 guests are all looking
forward to being treated and fed like
royalty should be a doddle know she took
her there on the path the sumptuous
dining room screams luxury for you
Colleen quickly serves Anna news Bush
not only will it prepare my guests for
the meal ahead but it also shows off
Colin's expensive approach to cooking
but it's not the only thing that's
expensive collect the menu which are
quite big it's not really placed it
anywhere it sounds like this is your
life ah
we'll need as a lender's to pop out from
the Hogan fireplace were away shoes
after the first amuse-bouche comes
another carrot mousse with coriander ice
cream and even a mistress let's see how
well you have time to get two appetizers
and two courses in you don't do things
like after you there's a lot going on
you know honestly sometimes less is more
they're delicious but it was quite a lot
of flavors to be said before you
actually didn't you main meal perhaps
maybe just one would have been enough
I admire Colin's Eiffel Tower sized
ambitions to provide a stunning
gastronomic experience but the minutes
are ticking by and the theatrics show no
sign of giving way to proper food see a
red rolling outside the Humber Bridge
it's only big enough for Tony for but I
just watched the waiter push up I was
like banging later tonight at the same
set 30 minutes have gone and we haven't
even taken waters yes
I'm not asking two men on the flavors
man and I want this food out of the
kitchen when they get to taste this food
that was blown away